(airplane propellers starting)
(dramatic music)
- It's absolutely deafening
inside this cockpit.
You have an engine that is
screaming loud in front of you.
The cockpit's 140 degrees inside.
Everything is shaking,
vibrating in its own different way.
Why would you wanna do
something like this?
Bottom line is every
pilot wants to go fast.
- Steve Hinton is trying
to set the fastest speed
ever accomplished with a propeller-driven
piston engine aircraft.
- To break this record
you have to be perfect.
This is the pinnacle of aviation.
- Steve's dad broke the
record at 499 miles an hour.
- [Steve] There's only few
people that have ever stood
on top of this mountain.
The Wright brothers, Jimmy D. Little,
Glenn Curtiss, Howard Hughes.
- Just these icons of aviation.
- And Steve believes that
he is the man to do it.
- 535 is the magic number.
If we go 535 miles an hour,
that's a new world record.
(dramatic music)
- [Announcer] Hold your
position, we got an emergency.
(sirens blaring)
- My dad was definitely a hero of mine.
He also air raced, he
set world speed records,
and won several races with an airplane
called the Red Baron.
And he's alive to tell the tale about it.
- [Reporter] At the scene of the crash
medics have recovered Steve Hinton
from the shattered cockpit of the Baron.
- This is serious business,
and I've been severely hurt,
I broke my back and broke my legs
when I crashed the Red Baron for instance,
but I was young and I healed well.
- [Reporter] And now
this MedEvac helicopter
is the key to survival for Steve Hinton.
- You know, it's funny being
part of an aviation family.
When Steve, Sr. crashed
crashed the Red Baron
it never even occurred to
me to say, "Don't fly."
You can't separate
someone from their soul.
(slow music)
- Fifteen years ago was the first time
I really got bit by this air racing bug.
I dug through my parents' attic and found
a bunch of old photographs of my dad
from his racing days and found his trophy,
which he got for setting
the world speed record.
He held that record for 10
years until Lyle Shelton
broke that same record
at 528 miles an hour.
It is still considered one of
the hardest records to break.
The allure, it's just kinda pulled me in;
it's like this gravitational force.
But having an opportunity
to break a speed record
I thought was beyond a long shot.
Our family operates a warbird museum
based in Chino, California,
that is dedicated
to preserving, maintaining,
flying these aircraft.
My sister and I had a crib
in my mother's office here
while she was doing the books.
And some of my earliest memories
are waddling out into the hanger
and seeing my dad working on an aircraft.
(slow music)
- You know, he was probably a baby
sittin' out next to the toolbox
when his dad was takin' an engine apart.
Before he could talk he
probably was already gettin' it.
- The warbirds, so to speak,
are special in our family.
We are really intrigued with
the mechanical end of 'em,
the history.
They were built for war,
they're built for combat,
and they're built for killing.
But there were the Apollo
spaceships in their day.
- [Steve] There is a mystique
that surrounds these aircraft.
There was no computers that built 'em;
they were all hand-built.
Calculated with slide
rulers, pencils, and paper.
- To be able to understand
how the entire aircraft works
is just a really important
part of being a pilot
of a World War II aircraft.
Steve had always grown
up with that expectation
that you'll really know your
airplane when you work on it.
- [Steve, Sr.] And once he started racing,
he started winning.
(upbeat music)
- I was able to win my first
year out at the age of 22,
which bested my dad's record of being
the youngest to win an air race.
And then I was lucky enough to win
seven of eight races over
the last eight years.
- [Steve, Sr.] And that was a big deal,
he won his first four big races.
He -- won and beat everybody
handily without any trouble.
- It was just this total Cinderella story.
How many men have tried
to win the unlimited gold
and have never even won a heat race?
- There's guys that have
done this for 40 years
and only won seven times.
I felt like the last way to
leave your impression on a sport
is to go after the speed record,
because once this breed
of airplane is extinct
it won't be capable of being broken again.
For this record attempt we've
come to a private ranch,
which our sponsor, Joe Clark, owns,
which is an ideal location for the record.
He's got his own runway
on it, and he's given us
the opportunity to try and make history.
- There's some better
places to do this at,
but the runway isn't long
and the terrain is horrible.
There are literally an
infinite amount of areas here
that you could safely land this airplane
on its belly and not get hurt.
- If the engine blows he's
gotta get it on the ground.
We got a lot of runway here,
and we have overruns at both ends.
(airplane engine roaring)
It's gonna take a lot of skill,
and concentration, and machinery.
I mean this machine's gonna be runnin'
at 3,600 horsepower,
and there's only maybe two
or three other airplanes
in the whole world that
can do this at this level.
(slow music)
- The aircraft that we're
using to break this record
is what's called a North
American P-51 Mustang,
and we've named it Voodoo.
P-51 changed the war.
The aerodynamics of the airplane were such
that it was far superior to
many other aircraft around it.
- [Steve, Sr.] You might
say it's an old warbird,
and, you know, there's new
airplanes that can do this,
and that's just not true.
That's as good as it's gonna get.
- [Steve] It's a small
air frame, which means
it's shaped like a
bullet; it's real quick,
and it really has lent itself into being
a nice racing platform.
- [Steve, Sr.] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
My dad and I aren't
emotionally close people;
it's a very business-type
of a relationship.
We've talked about mechanical
aspects and how things work,
but as far as how would you do
this, how would you do that,
I haven't gotten much
advice from him at all.
He thought it would be
more beneficial for me
to experience my own thought process.
- They don't have to say
"I love you" every day.
The fact that they work
together on things is the bond
and it's kinda the glue
that holds us together.
- I know you know this,
but I'll say it anyway,
the time of day makes a big difference,
and, you know, it's like
the -- with the clouds,
but the ground looks different every time,
so that's why the more flying the better.
- We're about two o'clock right now,
and we're gonna be doin' it
between two, three, four, five,
somewhere in there, so.
- [Steve, Sr.] He's assuming
a lot of responsibility,
which is a lot of load.
I've kept an eye on 'im quite a bit.
He's handling it well,
but I think it's adding
to the stress level that he doesn't need.
- Prior to flying the airplane
I'm 110 percent mechanic.
The big key to us breaking this record
will be the aerodynamics of the airplane
and the design is so solid that we can
push the limits a little bit more
than what it was designed for.
Every aspect of this airplane
is so far beyond the envelope
it was originally intended to do.
Because of that, the engine
is commonly breaking.
- This engine is going to
be completely stressed.
It's going to be flying at
power longer than it has to
during an air raid.
- There's a tremendous
amount of maintenance
that goes on with it.
That includes test flying at full power.
(dramatic music)
- It's probably the most dangerous part
of this record is the engine.
What you're trying to do is get it to go
to the absolute maximum without breaking.
- There's this fuse,
once we start opening up
the throttle on this
engine, that fuse gets lit.
We don't know now long the fuse is.
No one knows how long the fuse is.
It's a lot of passion.
You have mechanical failures,
you have lots of late nights.
You gotta always try and see that light
at the end of the tunnel, even
though you may not see it,
you have to have faith that it's there.
- [Man] Looking good.
- Should be starting up here
in the next half an hour.
Obviously, the first priority
is that this is a safe flight.
We're obviously going for a speed record,
but the priority is to
be on the ground safely.
So, if the airplane does have some sort
of an emergency or Mayday,
we ask that everybody just
stay away from the runway.
I'm not gonna swerve to miss
ya, so, get off the runway.
(laughing and applauding)
- Pilots have been
looking at the old record
for many, many years waiting
for someone to come and break it.
To do it he must fly over
this course four times,
two times in each direction
to come up with a final average speed.
He must exceed the current
record by one percent.
- My job today is to be the chase plane.
If I see something that doesn't look right
I'll be able to watch him and help him,
so I'll be running the shoulder with 'im.
- If we're lucky we'll get
one crack at this record.
If we're not successful we
are really rolling the dice
to try and set this thing again.
(dramatic music)
- [Joe] These engines are
like people: they talk to you,
and in this particular
case it's gotta last
probably 10, 15 minutes.
- [Steve] Once we start
opening up the throttle
on this engine it could go
within the first 45 seconds.
- [Man] Get off the runway!
- [Man] Out of the runway!
- [Woman] Get off the runway!
- [Woman] Get off the runway, now!
- [Man] Get off the runway,
hey, off the runway!
- I thought I heard off
power, but I'm not sure,
and I don't know what that means.
- So we were just settin'
up for making that attempt
on the speed record and climbed out,
got to altitude, started
coming up on power,
everything was going nice,
got the course in sight,
threw up on full power
for about 10 or 15 seconds
and got a little sneeze,
like a -- and then a boom,
and it blew a bunch of shit
out of the exhaust stacks,
so we declared a Mayday, and
cruised on in and landed.
It was still making power
just a lot of oil pressure.
So we don't know what the
issue is at the moment.
There is coolant all over the
right side of the airplane,
so we will go back to work and see
if we can figure out what's happening
and how to get her back in the sky.
- [Cameraman] Thanks, man.
- Yeah.
Fuck!
(slow music)
- Crew's gonna have to look it over
and determine what happened.
It could be major or it
could be something simple,
we don't know at this point;
but the airplane's here, Steve's here,
so if it just needs a part or
something, we'll find a way.
- You really have to be
ready for those punches
to get thrown at you in this industry
because it is 75-year-old equipment,
but I'm so proud of these guys.
Normal people wouldn't do
the stuff that we're doing,
they would've quit a long time ago.
(slow music)
- [Steve, Sr.] It's not natural to fly,
I don't care who you are.
You have to get experience.
Understanding limitations and
understanding consequences.
Unfortunately, we've had friends
who aren't with us anymore,
and Steve has gone through that.
- As a mother you can't go through
these kinds of things unaffected.
You vibrate with every core of your being
during these experiences.
I don't wanna watch him do this again.
And I know that's what they do.
They blow the engine, they
change it, and they go again,
and it's just not gonna
be very easy to watch.
- Alrighty, if you like, I like it.
(airplane engine starting)
The pilot has to fly perfect,
the airframe has to work perfect,
the engine needs to run perfectly.
Everything has to come
together for it to be perfect.
We're not doing this
record for somebody else;
we're not doing this for
another group of people;
we're not trying to prove that
we're faster than anybody;
we're doing this for ourselves.
Okay, I'm gonna start coming over the --.
- [Steve, Sr.] OK, clock is rollin'.
- [Steve] Got it.
It's absolutely deafening
inside this cockpit.
You have an engine that is
screaming loud in front of you.
There's 18 different gauges in the cockpit
that you're trying to keep track of.
In the midst of all this chaos
you talk to the engine,
talk to the airplane,
it's you and the piece of
equipment, you and the machine.
OK, I got -- on it, -- leave it there.
It's been an all consuming project
for the last four to five years.
All this work throughout the year,
all of these moments of dreaming,
it essentially comes down to 30 seconds.
- [Man] He's blowing
oil; he's losing power.
- [Man] Yup.
- [Man] Check the oil pressure.
- [Steve] Yeah, I'm gonna
turn her back around here.
The first thing in your mind is,
come on, you can hold together,
there's only a little bit left.
Alright, last lap, c'mon, Baby.
(slow music)
On the one hand it was successful,
we're back on the ground.
Between the third and fourth pass
the oil pressure started falling off,
so it'll be interesting
to see how the speeds
reflect the four passes.
We'll wait for about an hour
until Brain Utley from the
NAA does his calculations
and makes sure I didn't break
any altitude restrictions,
and then we'll get an
average of the four laps
and see what we got.
Everybody together!
- Let me walk you through the numbers,
'cause I think it's important
to know the numbers.
The old record, 528.33 --
- You said "old record," so
that means there's new record.
(laughing and applauding)
- You must exceed the current
record by one percent.
So with the first lap, the first pass,
Steven averaged 554.69 miles an hour,
absolutely fantastic.
On the second pass he averaged 527.34
for an average over the two passes of 541.
On the third pass he
averaged 528.48 miles an hour
for a three pass average of 536.84.
On the fourth pass, unfortunately,
he only averaged 515.6 miles an hour,
which dropped his overall
average down to 531,
and I'm sorry I can't
give you better news,
but, through the third lap, it was there.
But congratulations for a
great, great, great flight.
(applauding)
- [Steve] It's surreal when
he, you know, told us the speed
and this is the average.
It's like, huh, that's it.
The end.
No fairy tale ending, no
fireworks, no celebration,
it's just kind of this, huh.
- This engine ran real well,
but it unfortunately missed
the beat by about 30 seconds.
We do our best to figure
all the variables,
but that's racing.
- Before the fourth pass the
oil pressure began fluctuating
and these engines, when they
start losing oil pressure,
something is gonna
explode, and I was faced
with this decision of do
I go out, do I come back,
so I just quickly turned
the airplane around,
but I could feel that it
bled a lot of speed off.
I know the limitations of the airplane,
I know what I can get away with,
and I know what I can't get away with,
and this was a decision that
was right on the edge of that.
(upbeat music)
It's a bit hard going to sleep at night
'cause it'll keep me up.
You know, you always go
through the what ifs,
so I tend to try not to think about it,
and hopefully there will be
a next chapter at some point.
- You know, it's like
just missing Everest.
To set the record you have to beat
the previous record by one percent.
Doesn't sound like a lot, but
when you're pushing the speeds
that these guys are pushing,
it's very difficult to do.
- [Steve, Sr.] You know you
set a goal, and he went out
and executed it just like they'd planned
and, with any luck, Steve might
get another chance to do it.
- We know where to improve the airplane;
we know where to improve the engine
and that gives us hope that if we do
get a chance to do this again,
we'll be able to break that
535 mile an hour number.
As a matter of fact now we
have to go 536 miles an hour
'cause we have to break our
old record by one percent,
so here we go.
(slow music)